the craziest scandal in League of
Legends just got crazier we've got
thousands of dollars in fines perma bans
to ride eSports events allegations of
verbal and physical abuse allegations of
forgery and of course shady contracts
this story is getting wilder by the
minute and we got a lot of ground to
cover so buckle up alright so in case
you missed our last two videos about
this let's do a quick recap Griffin is a
league of legends team in the lck
korea's pro league they've had a little
bit of a Cinderella run over the last
few years where they started in
Challenger and worked their way all the
way up to worlds this year where they
placed fifth eighth but right before
worlds Griffin's coach CV max abruptly
left the team which started an entire
shitstorm to Griffon players said that
CV max was lying about Griffon on his
stream CV max responded by saying that
show the manager of Griffon banned him
from streaming volleys on the team to
prevent him from getting his name out
there and accused cv max of just getting
lucky and saying that he had nothing to
do with Griffin successes on top of that
allegations began to surface that Joe
may have strong-armed a player on
Griffon kanava into signing an
unfavorable contract still 8 Griffin's
parent company put out an apology and
Cho resigned but then chose in an
interview where he threw a bunch of
allegations back on the CD max then some
senators got involved and right Korea
began investigating all right is that
everything that brings us to the present
where we have a ton of new developments
in this story I honestly can't pick
which of these is the absolute craziest
so let's just run through them all
chronologically first ride Korea put out
a competitive ruling on Gryphon and the
beginning of it is that they find
Gryphon about eighty-five thousand US
dollars
they've also indefinitely banned both
show and CD max from all right
sanctioned league of legends events
their careers and league are basically
over in a translation from Kerr aizen's
Kevin Kim Riot writes that Cho behaved
improperly during the whole situation
with Konami for a quick refresher the
whole issue with Konami was that he was
forced by Griffin allegedly to sign a
long term contract in order to secure a
higher transfer fee for the org when he
was alone to a Chinese team called JD G
show alleged that Konami participated in
tan
ring which riot eventually said no he
didn't that is super complicated but
basically Konami didn't [ __ ] up the
problem is Cho absolutely did see
according to that translation Ryan found
that show is guilty of strong-arming
Konami into signing an unfavorable
contract show main Konami a minor
process his own player transfer and
pressured him unfairly presumably in
reference to getting a better transfer
fee when he was loaned out to jdg Riot
also stated that show added a casa
Konami contract that excluded his time
on a loan to jdg as part of the contract
period which that would effectively trap
him on Griffin for way longer than he
expected to when he signed the contract
meanwhile for CB max riot wrote in their
decision that they found evidence and
instances of cv max verbally and
physically abusing players on Griffin
and personally just as an aside that
seems like a pretty good reason to ban
someone if it's true that it's Griffin
is also being fine as I already
mentioned but that's because riot found
that there were people in higher up
positions in Griffin who either knew
about the situation didn't stop it or
otherwise helped show make it happen
they also wrote that if they find
Griffin doing anything like this again
they could accrue further penalties up
to and including losing their spot in
the lck that's some wild stuff but it's
really the tip of the iceberg Korean
senators had Kyung ha who was looking
into this whole situation released a
statement calling the whole thing apart
senator Haas said that riots decision to
punish Stevie Max could be against a
Korean law designed to protect the
whistleblowers the law comes with up to
three years of jail time for anybody who
breaks in the way that Senator Haas sees
it Stevie Max has courage to speak out
against Griffin is admirable and he
shouldn't be punished for it notably
nothing in the statement mentioned
anything about the allegations of verbal
or physical abuse just the allegations
of corruption going on in Griffin
senator Hall also spoke in a separate
article about what he found out when he
looked into the situation regarding
Kenobi's contrast allegedly according to
some translations of an article
published by inven korea griffin used a
fraudulent contract to trick kanabi
unfortunately i don't have a really
solid translation of that article that i
really trust right now but i want to say
that those allegations are extremely
serious because not only is senator ha
alleging that griffin broke the law
but also that they horribly mistreated a
minor something that I want to note here
that our translator told us is that
Senator ha is really famous for being a
get [ __ ] done kind of guy our translator
told us that while other politicians
take a long time passing something or
investigating something
senator ha has a long record of
approaching difficult topics and not
being afraid to blow things up anyway
within this allegedly Senator ha is
saying that Griffon fours legal
documents and honestly that to me is the
craziest part of this whole story so I'm
really sorry I can't go further into
depth about it I just need a better
translation and you can be sure that
we're working on it and we'll let you
know more about that as soon as we
understand that ourselves
anyway after Rice announcement cv max
took to twitch and talked about a
conversation he had with a riot Korea
employee on his stream CV max alleged
that the riot employee said that CV max
told a player quote do whatever the [ __ ]
pleases you and that constitutes a
verbal abuse our translator specifically
noted that instead of the word [ __ ] he
really said do whatever your dick tells
you to do but it basically means the
same thing once you translate it TV max
goes on to allege that he never used
that word the one that's either dick or
[ __ ] and says that riot won't let him
listen to the recordings they allege
that they have of him verbally abusing
players then still eight made a
statement on their website about
literally everything up to this point in
it they claim that kanabi transfer to JD
g of his own free will that he was never
threatened into signing a contract that
griffin didn't do any document forging
and that still 8 are gonna be taking
legal action against cv max and then
invent published an article in which
they interviewed several players who are
on Griffin who allege that they were
verbally and physically abused by CB max
in the interview Griffin coach Kaos says
that he saw C V Max throw his notebook
and shake players by the collar sword
one of the players on Griffin also says
quote he also said I'm disgusting and
that he can't handle me he said that if
we lose because of me he follow me to
the end of the world to get revenge or
that he'd kill me another player
Tarzan says that he wasn't personally
the victim of any physical or verbal
abuse but that he did witness C V Max
insult other players calling them
[ __ ] and saying they quote [ __ ]
suck and rather another player alleges
that C V max pinched another player so
hard it left a bruise that player by the
way was chosen
rather also alleges that after a scrim
two years ago CD maths told one player
quote if I was a teammate in that game I
would have called you a [ __ ] who's a
mom died that's [ __ ] crazy and I
don't even really know what that means
anyway there is a lot more to that
interview and I really recommend reading
it if you want to know more about the
whole situation but the summary is a lot
of players and the coach of Gryphon are
backing up the allegations of verbal and
physical abuse that riot put out now as
a counterpoint allegedly that [ __ ]
whose mom died insult was directed at
Newt who was Griffon support player at
the time Newt has since gone on CEO
Max's stream to say that he was okay
with being called that and he doesn't
view it as verbal abuse and to fold that
out some people have said that this kind
of coaching style isn't all that unusual
in Korea recently retired player song
you and went on a stream and said that
if this is a band worried the offense
pretty much every coach you've ever had
would be banned on top of that former
league of legends caster and personality
Montecristo tweeted that he'd heard some
very similar things about the korean
coaching style as well now just because
it's the style in the region doesn't
really make it okay following the
publication of that interview cv max
took to twitch again to refute some of
those players claims we have a
translation of that too so let's break
it down first senior max said that Jovi
Doron and Newt all contacted him after
the news broke at the time that the
alleged abuse occurred cv max says that
all three of those players whom he says
he directed the most abuse towards all
consented to his coaching style
additionally cv max alleges that even
those players parents consented to that
coaching style and he alleges that both
the players and parents have thanked him
for helping them improve and the players
have asked that their cases not be
brought up in this dispute anyway cv max
says that Tarzan's claims don't make
sense then because cv max alleges that
tarzan actually asked for harsher
coaching himself cv max shows what he
alleges was a text conversation he had
with Tarzan in which Tarzan asked for
quote spicier coaching after performing
poorly in scrims
according to C V Max this alleged
conversation with Tarzan happened in the
post season break but before world and
the way TV max sees it it basically
contradicts all of Tarzan's claims
anyway that basically does it for the
whole CD Max versus the players thing
but just in case you forgot about the
whole thing about Konami and corruption
aha released the entire contract in full
and we have a partial translation and
guess what the contract has a few shady
causes surprising absolutely no one
who's been in eSports for more than four
days the first weird clause in the
contract is that if a player is sick or
injured and has to be hospitalized for
30 days or more they can be fired by
Griffin for no other reason and with no
warning and crazier if they're fired for
that reason they're not allowed to join
another team for 12 months the contract
also states that a player can be fired
at any time with no warning if their
play is found to be lacking if the team
can't get in contact with player that is
of course another reason to be fired on
top of a fine hand their salary will be
taken away and of course it also states
that if the player uses the Griffin IP
after they leave the team and any way to
make money Griffin gets to claim all of
the profits that's a lot of shady stuff
and apparently we're only scratching the
surface I know that this started as a
pretty crazy story but this has
ballooned into probably the most
incredible scandal in eSports history at
this point
Colin already told you about how this
could impact the way that Korean League
of Legends contracts our eSports
contracts in general are written from
now on but now I think it could do even
more we've got serious criminal lawsuits
allegations of physical and verbal abuse
and now a minor being mistreated
this is bucks all right let's do a quick
recap here just to wrap everything up if
we possibly can in less than like ten
minutes
Stevie Max and Cho are both banned
Stevie Max because he allegedly
physically and verbally abused players
Stevie Max says that that's not quite
what happened that he apologized or that
it wasn't necessarily verbal abuse or
physical abuse but riot won't show him
the tapes the players on Griffin said
that it actually happened Stevie Mac
says that some players asked for that
kind of coaching and many others in the
community say that that's just the style
of coaching in Korea meanwhile in the
case of Cho he was banned because of
some shady contract stuff with kanabi
the senator looking into that says that
yeah it's about as shady as you expect
and even more shady than we could
possibly imagine up to and including
strong-arming a minor in defining an
unfavorable contract and forging
documents in order to make him do it
all right that is a lot but there's
gonna be even more ground to cover I'm
sure something Crazy's gonna happen
before we even publish this video so you
can be sure we're gonna look into this
even
and as soon as we know something you
will - okay I honestly don't think they
have a sign is that big a deal I'm gonna
be real it literally doesn't matter dude
if people see that there's an exit sign
they know that we have fire safety has
like standards here it goes there's an
exit sign over there it's the one like
way back there right next ed door yeah
it's fine it's just we have an exit sign
we have to have them I'm sorry if you
have to see them every time I move my
head like an idiot but like I move my
head like an idiot and then the egg of
the sign is gonna be there Andrew wants
me to apologize to you all right is that
okay for you Andrew my apology to the
fans that's true I hope you guys can
accept this apology